my interview with 60 year old throat
cancer survivor val kilmer
who is reprising the iconic ice man in
next summer's sequel top gun maverick
do you really have to work damn it
entertainment tonight was on the set of
top gun back in 1985 so we want to show
you something okay
my father was in the air force i was
excited to be able to get to
see an aspect of the navy that civilians
can't see
val what do you remember about that i
remember
talking can be a challenge at times for
val but his outlook couldn't be more
optimistic how are you doing
i'm doing nothing but
i've been run over by it
you can see val in his new film peter
which hits theaters and on demand friday
i got you the project is particularly
special because
he co-stars alongside 28 year old
daughter mercedes
i just want to be your dad now that's
okay
thank you what did you learn from
working with your dad how
to work with actors with different
abilities like
my dad's speech being compromised and
how much we
all have to gain from hiring more actors
with different abilities